hi everyone thank you so much for
joining us today
and thank you lab roots and bio-rad um
for
giving the opportunity to talk to you
about
our experience with droplet digital pcr
at biodesign
so the title of my talk today is
blood-based detection of egfr and k-ras
mutations
for nsclc patients using multiplexed
droplet digital pcr
my name is hestia mellert i am the
senior director of development
at biodesics i've been with the company
for just over five years now
and have had a major part in the
development of many of our
tests including droplet digital pcr
applications
we'll start out with a brief overview of
biodesics and what we do as a company
then we'll move into the laboratory
workflows for ddpcr
applications and we'll focus our
attention on a
laboratory-developed test called
genistrat that looks at somatic variants
in dna as well as rna fusions
then i will introduce the next
generation of droplet digital pcr that
being the qx1 instrumentation
i will tell you a little bit about our
experience early on with bio-rad as they
were developing this instrument
um as well as now in the present as we
have
these instruments um in our laboratory
in our clinical laboratory setting
and finally we'll close out the session
talking about a few case studies using
droplet digital pcr
in the clinic specifically i'm looking
at
how this technology can be used
um both to diagnose treatment but also
in monitoring treatment outcomes
biodesics really has two core business
units
and they're represented here on this
slide by
by these two circles we have a
commercial side as well as a pharmacide
both of these are supported by our two
clinical laboratories the first ones
located in boulder colorado in our
corporate
location and this laboratory has
certifications with clea
cap clep and is iso 1345 accredited
and then we have an additional clinical
laboratory
doing testing out of desoto kansas as
well
on the commercial side of things so
we're looking at the white
circle now in the venn diagram we've got
six now on market tests actually we've
just brought up
our sars coke ii total antibody test and
and that complements the molecular
testing that we are doing with drop of
digital pcr
and in addition to that we have two um
suites of tests one looks for to help
with the diagnosis of indeterminate
nodules
in the lung those are the notify cdt and
xl2 tests
and the second is following diagnosis of
cancer
helping to understand the molecular
underpinnings of that cancer using
liquid biopsy
which is the genestrat test which we'll
go into in more detail in this
presentation
and the varistrat test which complements
this test in prognosticating
so in addition to those tests that are
available to physicians
as on-market laboratory developed
testing
we also have a robust pharma partnering
business
which utilizes our clinical laboratories
we do testing anything from early
pre-clinical studies all the way through
phase 3
trial sample testing using these
technologies
these are the the core platforms that we
use in the laboratories
we consider ourselves generally platform
agnostic
that is we bring platforms and
technology into biodesics
because it answers a key clinical
question in the lung
um care continuum and so because of that
you can see
here that we have technologies both
supporting genomics and proteomics
um and really do span the gamut from
targeted pcr
like droplet digital pcr to genome wide
ngs platforms we look at proteomics
with maldi tof mass spec lcms as well as
elisa testing
and if you dig deeper into what those
technologies really do
provide to the community it's a nice
complement of both looking at the tumor
itself and profiling the molecular
underpinnings of tumor biology as well
as supporting that
with the immune response or the body's
response to that tumor
and immune profiling and so these
technologies
all together um can really give us a lot
of different types of tools to answer
those those burning questions
this is a map i'm showing you
specifically for genistrat
where our laboratory developed tests are
used across the united states
and you can see that although we do have
testing happening across the entire
united states we tend to focus and have
a large number of tests coming from
that northeast corridor there where
there is a high prevalence
of lung cancer in our communities
so let's focus now a little bit more on
our genomics
and specifically our droplet digital pcr
test
that's the genistrat test
the genistrat test
addresses through liquid biopsy
mutations that are common
and actionable in non-small cell lung
cancer
and you can see those mutations here
on the slide we look for egfr
sensitizing mutations
exon 19 deletions l858r
we look for the more uncommon mutations
in egfr
in exon 18 and 20
as well as t790m resistance mutations
and in addition we can look at mutations
in k-ras
and in b-raf those all happen um
by looking at the dna the circulating
dna
or cell-free dna and we do this by
um supplying our test sites with the
strac
cf dna ii which is the blood collection
tube that's specifically designed
to stabilize nucleic acid or cf dna
or ambient temperature shipment and in
addition to looking at mutations from
dna
and small insertions deletions we also
utilize the strec rna tube to look for
circulating rna as well and this allows
us to
look at those actionable mutations that
are actually due to rearrangement
rearrangements in the genome
and generate fusion transcripts so there
we're looking for
alp fusions rep fusions and ros1 fusions
and you can see the partners that are
specifically measured
underneath each in the table provided
so the pre-analytic pieces of genistrat
include a test
going out to the community or the
physician that is interested in ordering
the test
they draw these blood tubes for us
and then they can ship them back to us
at ambient temperature for testing
in the centralized laboratory
once those tubes arrive to the
laboratory
we initiate the genistrat workflow which
i'm describing here
to you um the first thing that happens
is we accession those samples
into a laboratory information management
system um and give them unique
de-identified number and then
that is carried with them throughout the
process
the first step is extracting the nucleic
acid
so we have extraction methods for both
rna as well as
dna and once we have that nucleic acid
the rna is converted
to complementary dna or cdna by an rt
step
and then that's where the droplet
digital pcr workflow is initiated for
the genestrat test
and up till very recently we were using
the qx200 system
that is a relatively manual system we
have the manual generator
of droplets there then we go into a
thermal cycling step on a standard
thermocycler
and then we read those droplets
following thermocycling
and then we are able to now analyze each
individual droplet
using two-dimensional plots like i'm
showing there
that process can then be
essentially analyzed and reviewed
generating results for genestrad so
either
identifying that there was a mutation of
interest for example an egfr mutation
in that circulating cell free dna sample
or
that there was no mutation detected and
the whole process
is designed to work really within
48 hours and i will show you on the next
slide on what that looks like in the lab
in practice
the turnaround time of genistrat is
displayed here in this pie
chart you can see in the dark blue that
about 50
of the samples that come into the lab
upon arrival
can be then reported back to the
physician and the patient within
24 hours and an additional 40 percent
by 48 and so this really provides us
with
um fast turnaround times that allow the
physician and patient
to make informed decisions with
molecular information about their tumor
upon first treatment and this has been a
really
kind of important characteristic of
being able to use this droplet digital
pcr
technology in our workflow in the lab is
the turnaround time that physicians are
really looking for
to make informed decisions about
treatment
to focus a little bit on egfr so this is
our
um ddptr testing specifically for egfr
you can see here the clinical
sensitivity
specificity and overall concordance for
each one of those actual mutations that
i
mentioned earlier as well as our c797s
resistance mutation
and what you can see here is that the
clinical specificity
in our initial studies for validation is
extremely good
um really demonstrating that the
technology doesn't sacrifice specificity
although it does absolutely um
have wonderful sensitivity levels that
are really required
to have application in liquid biopsy
where the cell-free components from the
tumor can be at really
quite low levels in circulation so the
droplet digital pcr
is really a good tool for liquid biopsy
testing because of its
rate specificity as well as superb
sensitivity
this is an additional study that we did
once we were on market
um with a partner these were the aura 3
samples from astrazeneca and so you can
see in real world settings
as well with the aura 3 trial samples
our specificity
was very near 100 in each case
and our sensitivity was also
quite good for the different egfr
mutations
it's interesting to note here that we
identified along with astrazeneca that
there are certain certain patients i
should say
that do not shed cell free nucleic acid
and what we identified was that
independent of which
type of technology you might use on
those patients
they're considered non-shedders and
although their tumor
may contain some egfr mutation that
liquid biopsy
is unable to detect it
okay so now let's move in to the qx1
as i mentioned earlier this is the next
generation from bio-rad for
digital pcr and i wanted to introduce
you what is new about this technology
there's
quite a couple of exciting developments
and then i'll give you the experience
that we've had both during the
development
and now um with the instrumentation
so i introduced this a little bit
earlier um
this is the 200 system with a manual
droplet generator
and as implemented in our laboratory to
run the genestrat liquid biopsy test
it takes about 30 minutes of hands-on
time
to generate droplets then you take those
droplets
um in their 96 well plate and put them
into a thermocycler and that
cycling program takes about two hours
that would be hands off time
and then a technician would need to come
back to the laboratory
and transfer that plate onto the reader
which is another about
two hours worth of time so if you're
um doing crunching the math here it
takes about
12 hours of tech time some is um
continuous when they're doing the
droplet generation and some is
you know transferring plates in between
these different steps
um to do five plates in a day and so
although this has been
um you know worked into our workflow in
this manual way in the clinical
laboratory
of course it's not always ideal to have
to have so much
interaction with the workflow and the
more we can automate things
um the better better it is for our
clinical applications
and that's where the qx1 really um does
shine
so here what this figure is showing you
is that the generation
the thermal cycling and the reading are
now
all in one automated workflow within
this larger box called the qx1
so the qx1 also has the capability of
taking up to five plates at a time
and so you can load your five plates
and essentially walk away from the
instrument
and the additional benefit to the qx1
above and beyond the throughput benefits
that you get in the automation
they've added additional colors so the
qx200
manual system had both hex and fan
channels
and now we have four different channels
that are
able to be used within the qx1 and so
you can design
assays that are more complex and get
more information out of a given run and
a given amount of sample and so that's
another
great benefit to the new technology
the qx1 ddpcr system expands upon the
most proven digital pcr technology
for unmatched precision and sensitivity
in absolute
quantification with automated and walk
away operations
for multiple plates and the system's
easy to use
supports regulatory compliance and
enables more answers per sample
with advanced multiplexing so you can
see here
with the reagents now as well and there
are
really easy to use oils that can be
imported into the instrument with
barcodes as well as barcoding on the
plates so you can really trace
i have traceability of your specimens
and your reagents throughout the process
so all in all we've taken essentially
a workflow where if you wanted to look
for example 20
targets because there's two channels
that would require 10 plates
and no if you have two systems running
in parallel for example you could get
that done in about 12 hours of tech time
and now we've taken that same thing and
with a capacity of
five plates being able to input into the
system and walk away and four targets
you've greatly reduced that time to
about two hours of actual hands-on
tech time so you can see really the
benefit
and throughput and the interaction with
the instrument
have really have improved with the
automated system
and the other benefit of course to
automating is that you can get more
consistency in your workflow
so droplet generation can be
manually a more difficult process that
requires trained technicians
we are lucky at biodesics to have a
staff of
very talented technicians that can
generate droplets manually very
efficiently but the nice thing about
having a system like this
is that you don't have to to worry about
that piece you take your master mix
you mix it with your template of
interest and the instrument does the
rest
so you can load it onto a cartridge that
looks much like a fancy 96 well plate
essentially
scan the plate into the instrument again
up to five
and that's it the instrument does the
rest until
data is ready for you to analyze
so just to review some of the key
benefits that um we've
we've found while we started to use this
instrumentation
it's an automated walk-away operation
it has a five plate capacity it has
advanced multiplexing capabilities using
four colors now
rather than the two that were on the
original 2x1 systems
and just to kind of elaborate on that a
little bit
that doesn't mean that you can only look
at four different targets in fact
there's a lot of different
um ways that you can mix probes and
um change their concentrations
essentially
to get even more information so
increasing from two colors to four
colors can actually be quite a
significant increase in the
amount of information that you can gain
from your sample
so those two types of things could be
amplitude multiplexing or probe mixing
for example
unless it's presented there
it's easy to use of course as i
mentioned earlier
the the less time you need to take
training
technicians um to make sure that you've
got quality data of course that that's
definitely a benefit
and then it also has um cf
r21 part 11 compliance for its software
and the barcodes help you to track
consumables and allow you to manage
your samples as they go through the
workflow
okay next we're going to move into a few
slides that i put together
that presents some of the data that
biodesign generated alongside bio
during alpha and beta testing of the qx1
instruments
so initiated with alpha testing where we
focused on some of the
mutation tests that were important of
course to us
looking at non-small cell lung cancer
and so we decided to start out by
looking at our egfr and k-ras mutation
tests
and it's important to note here that
in the past our genistrat test
is using individual assays to look at
the mutation
in one channel and then the wild type
control in the other
and so in that way you have to run
additional assays to look for example at
each
variant of interest a rash g12c
different than k rs g12b
etc and so the nice thing here was that
we were able to use the four
color channels to actually multiplex now
to more extent and be able to
identify different mutations within the
same
liquid biopsy sample and assay run
we found that the assay set up was
relatively straightforward
again mixing your um assay of interest
with your template
and then putting it into the instrument
it doesn't get
much easier than that and the software
we were able to work with them on the
software that they have developed
and they've really made it a nice
interactive
environment for us to do the data
analysis on the back end
once the alpha testing was done which
happened at bio-rad
in pleasanton california our feedback
and feedback from other laboratories
was taken and they you know made some
adjustments
and then they contacted us again when
they were ready to place
some instruments for beta testing and so
these
pictures here are actually our um
our technical director and some of our
lab technicians and research associates
being trained at um on the beta
instrument at biodesics
in boulder colorado and during the beta
test
we ran um approximately 21 plates or
over 2 000 different targets through our
through the instrument um over about a
three week period of time
back in july of last year
so the we what we found again was that
the the instrument was easy to use it
was easy to train individuals to use the
instrument
we really appreciated the fact that it
conserves
sample because you can get that
additional information out of the same
aliquot sample the data analysis
was pretty straightforward and
we liked the fact that it still allows
you to look at the two-dimensional
thoughts that we're used to looking at
with the qx200 system as well as giving
additional options to look in more
three-dimensional space now that there's
four
targets per reaction or four channels i
should say a reaction
this slide shows some data that we've
generated while we were in
beta so this was an
assay that was generated
with egfr liquid biopsy testing in mind
it contains a wild-type egf probe
that is in the region of c797s
the assay also contains probes that
detect
t790n l858r
and c797s and there's actually two
different nucleotide changes
that are commonly causing c797s so you
can identify both of them as
you can see there so this was one of the
the first
examples of a higher multiplex test that
employed all four channels of the qx1
and you can see on the top that's how
you can look in two-dimensional
space for the droplets that are negative
and positive for each of the targets of
interest
and then on the bottom is another view
of the same data this allows you to look
at the concentration in copies per
microliter of each one of your channels
or your mutations of interest
and calculate the the concentration
within your sample
this assay was also done with the 4x
super mix from bio-rad um this is
another improvement that isn't
necessarily directly related to the qx1
but it is a really nice improvement
because it allows you to
use more sample as well and this is
becoming
you know more and more obvious as we
look at liquid biopsy samples that
the more sample that you can put into
the system
the better your sensitivity or your
chances of being able to see that rare
mutation would be
so by increasing to a 4x master mix that
allows you to put
more of the sample into each reaction
during beta we were also asked to run
some experiments for bio-rad that
specifically
looked at the the accuracy of
the test so here we are using the
national measurement institute standard
on the qx1 and you can see that
our average concentration was right at
around 2000 copies per microliter
to 2100 was the target concentration
that was advertised by national
measurement institute standard to be the
absolute concentration of the sample
and then in addition across these
specimens we saw
a cv of 1.6 so you can see here
really a lot of nice consistency and
precision
across multiple reactions using this
standard
next we tested some of our own um
specimens that we have in our laboratory
we wanted to see how the instrument
would perform
when we used actual clinical samples and
so here are a few different examples
um our our duplex test is in blue
and then the quadruple quadruplex tests
are in red and green here and what you
can see
is that running the qx 200 in a duplex
type of test
for each one of these variants is very
equivalent to what we were able to
obtain running the same sample
through the qx1 workflow and that was
true both for looking at positive
samples
that were detected using all of those
different sets
systems as well as the different
multiplexing um strategies on the qx1
but it's also important to note that we
didn't see any false positive or any um
signal coming up in the qx1 versus qx200
in these samples
this is additional information in
addition to the egfr
assay we also developed an
assay for k-rats with bioride
and this assay looked at cdnv
g12c b and b and so here again these are
clinical specimens
and what you can see here that there's
really nice consistency
across both positive and negative um
detection of k-ras mutations in
nsclc patient sam samples so again
rep just demonstrating that the qx1
system
functions much like our current approved
genistrat test
that's run on the qx200 on clinical
samples
okay so the last piece of the talk we're
going to
dive in a little bit to some data
that uses droplet digital pcr
um out of liquid biopsy or blood samples
for the purpose of monitoring
the first is a case study that was
published in 2019 with dr
bolling here we're looking
at a patient that is a female never
smoker
that presented with new onset seizures
and was diagnosed with
extensive brain and bony metastatic
positive
lung adenocarcinoma and upon molecular
testing with genistrat
initially she was bound to have an egfr
exon 19 deletion
mutation she was
initiated on treatment at that time
the the treatment was given was
generally a first generation tyrosine
kinase inhibitor of course now
it may be osprite nib so she was given
that treatment
and then acquired resistance and the
gfrt-79
m mutation as it emerged um at that time
she was switched to osmotinib
and over time then began to have
progressive disease
and so um we did look
at biodesics retrospectively at this
specimen
um after she had just discontinued
therapy
due to resistance and disease
progression for the resistance mutation
797s
which we do now have developed in our
clia lab and is a new york state
approved assay for us
um that we're using in the trial setting
about
10 of nsclc cases are c797s resistance
mutations
um another common alteration upon
resistance is net amplification
so let's look more closely at what this
looks like over time as we monitor these
samples
looking at the cell free dna by droplet
digital pcr
so at first you can see at time zero she
had this was
our time zero is one um she started
osmotiv treatment so you can see that
both the dell 19 mutation
is high um the y-axis representing the
allele frequency in the
in the biopsy sample and t790m is also
present
and upon us britain you can see at about
just under 50 days both egfr
signals have gone below the limit of
detection of the test or down to zero
if you will and that remains to be so
for about 100 days
and then upon um
further testing we could start to see
the recurrence of the disease even from
the liquid biopsy sample itself
and we saw both the egfr l19 and t790m
come back
as well as starting to see the emergence
now of a c797s mutation and you can see
that they really do increase pretty
dramatically
over time once the resistance
occurs and you can see the recurrence of
disease as well
in the associated scans
so this demonstrates in one case steady
how
using a sensitive technology that has a
relatively
fast turnaround time with a non-invasive
method like a liquid biopsy
can help us to monitor the mutations
that we're seeing
in from blood as these patients are
treated
and become resistant to disease
to therapy this is a another example
this is actually data that was presented
from astrazeneca and this was
part of their flora sample set
which is the first line for
degreaso and what you can see here
as well are two examples of the dynamics
of egfr over time looking at both
the mutations l858r as well as c797s and
t790m
um and you can see the dynamics will be
different from patient to patient
but overall um the recurrence
of the egfr mutations from the cell-free
dna
correlates with resistance to
the drug and recurrence of disease the
one interesting
thing i would say though about this
study
was that it also recognized that in in
many cases ct dna progression
preceded or co-occurred with the resist
progression of disease or the pd
so that was in 66 of the patients
in this study and in general the median
ct dna progression
lead time was about 2.7 months
on the progressive disease based on
resist
and so it's interesting to note here
that perhaps in
some cases the molecular signature in
in the blood can precede
being able to see the actual progression
of disease
so in conclusion um blood-based
approaches have become
an integral part of biomarker strategies
and drug discovery and development
of course droplet digital pcr as well as
other technologies that
must have really high sensitivity um
to be able to look for the rare mutation
events that will be
in circulation and so this is really a
key
highlight of droplet digital pcr and its
capabilities as it applies to liquid
biopsy
of course it's not only whether or not
the test is sensitive
that is important but also whether or
not the results can be back
with the physician and patient to be
informative for next steps and their
treatment plans
and that's where the turnaround time
becomes really quite important
and we have even with the manual
workflow been able to really implement a
fast turnaround time for our physicians
um to this end however with the qx1
you can see from what we've presented
and seen in
here that the qx1 is going to be able to
do that even better right so we'll be
able to
run five plates for example with a walk
away strategy that allows us to run
um more and gain information on more
samples
than what our current workflow would
allow
the additional benefits of having a poor
target
approach rather than the two target
approach
obviously also will increase the amount
of information
that one can get and i'm really looking
forward to seeing
how the scientific community
leverages those extra channels with
unique types of assay design
to really gain as much information as we
can out of these limited sample types
like a liquid biopsy sample
we saw that the interplay precision was
was quite excellent with a cv of 1.6
we saw that the copy numbers between the
quatraplex
and the equivalent duplex assay that we
have approved were very equivalent to
each other
and we also definitely appreciated the
hands
on time being diminished by using this
qx1 system
and um since since then we have actually
implemented
the qx ones into the biotestix
laboratory we have
new two new instruments um that we are
now working with
um and really as the assay developer
at biodiesex i'm looking forward to
getting
some time to to work on those
instruments and learning as much as i
can about how they can
help increase information content
that we can get out of our specimens so
with that i think i will close
out with an acknowledgement slide i
wanted to thank
of course the biodesics team here we are
being socially distanced with our masks
as the laboratory team is still working
around the clock now not only to support
our um our patients with an sclc
and with indeterminate nodules but also
to support those
patients that are questioning their
covid
status and so these this team here in
boulder
is running our coded ddpcr test as well
as genistrat
and also wanted to say thank you to the
biorad team from the digital biology
group
who obviously have been a major support
in
us implementing droplet digital pcr into
the clinical laboratory um so with that
i think i will um close out the session
and i am really looking forward to
hearing um if anyone has any questions
or follow-ups for me
thank you